the Prophet Mohammad's our Allah Allahu
sallam said verily this matter Islam
will reach where day and night have
reached and it will not leave a house of
mud or a house of fir except that Allah
will bring this religion into it doesn't
mean that everyone is going to become
Muslim but it doesn't mean that they
will receive the message brothers and
sisters earlier this year we witnessed
this saying of the Prophet my house our
lamp
right before our eyes when we went to
Namibia and Botswana we saw people
living in houses of fur people living in
houses of mud embrace Islam in fact a
hundred of them embraced Islam last year
ie rahat over 5,000 people accept the
slam from all around the world now for
the price of less than a cup of coffee
you receive the reward of people
accepting Islam across the globe on your
scale of good deeds to person accepts
Islam you will share the reward of every
single good deed they do every will bow
every prayer every letter of the Quran
that they read this is your opportunity
do you want to be part of this road why
are you waiting for what are you waiting
for click the button and donate now
[Music]